x-men apocalypse is finally out I saw
this movie really early and I've been
dying to talk some spoilers about this
because unlike civil war which I really
loved this movie actually has some
spoilers and some things to talk about
some people die some crazy shit happens
so you guys have already seen my review
I'm not going to rear 'view the movie I
really like this movie
I think it's underrated I think that
critics are being a little too harsh on
it and I think a lot of that has to do
with the fact that this movie requires
you to really pay attention to every
other film that took place in this
series thus far and when there's this
many movies especially when one of them
involves a lot of time travel and
world-changing and almost really
eliminating an entire film that can get
a little bit muddled you have to really
pay attention to focus on every other
thing that's happened to really feel the
weight of a lot of the arcs in this film
or what certain things have implications
for in regards to the future for
instance you have to pay attention to
x-men 1 & 2 which came out in the year
2000 in 2003 because this film shows the
beginnings of the relationship between
Jean Grey and Scott Summers the after
remember would took place in first class
with more attackers and Professor X
those events also weigh on this film and
he had to keep in mind the warped
timeline of Days of Future past because
now people view mystique as a hero
tons of people look up to her you have
to remember all of these little
important pieces of information to
really feel the full weight of certain
things that take place in this film most
of the other films didn't really require
that - except for maybe the first three
and it's easy to follow a trilogy and
feel the implications of everything that
takes place but with this film you
really have to be a fan to really feel
the weight of what's going on see I
rewatched all of the x-men movies except
for origins because I really hate
origins it's the only x-men movie I
don't feel like were you watching every
once in a while I'll watch x-men 3 just
because I watched 1 & 2 and I feel like
having the finality but x-men origins is
really the only one that I just like no
I can't watch that anymore so I had them
fresh in my mind I had the events fresh
in my mind and I was pumped for
apocalypse because I felt the weight of
those films and I understood where
everything was going and when I watched
apocalypse
it can easily be taken as a bit muddled
I think for someone who isn't really
well-versed in the x-men films I think
if you just went into apocalypse without
having experienced the other x-men films
at least semi recently it'd be kind of
like me walking into Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows part-2 without
having seen part one or any of the other
Harry Potter films because this film
really is a culmination of all of the
x-men films thus far and I really
enjoyed it I mean I pretty much loved it
I don't quite get the criticism but
let's talk about spoilers Weapon X I did
not know Wolverine was in this movie so
when he came out of that thing and
started slicing dudes up I was in heaven
I had no idea I was going to get that
these are actually surprisingly
difficult to hold within your fingers I
feel for you Wolverine after I saw the
first trailer for Apocalypse I stayed
away from the trailers on a lot of
people were talking about this final
trailer and being spoiler heavy so I
okay I'm just not gonna watch it so when
Weapon X AKA Logan / Wolverine stepped
out of that box I was so pumped to see
that and he went nuts blood shitting
face and flesh was just flying it was
awesome it was so great fanservice sure
maybe but I mean hey I'm a fan so I was
pleasantly serviced by Wolverine I'll
take it
havock also dies in this film which was
sad because it gave him a little bit
more of an emotional attachment in this
film you introduced his brother Scott
Summers
I liked havoc a lot in first class he
was a fun character so it was sad to see
him perish in this movie but it gave us
one of the best scenes as well because
following that death Quicksilver came in
with Annie Lennox and that was just
great I thought it topped the
Quicksilver scene in Days of Future past
along with another Quicksilver scene
towards the end he walks up to
apocalypse and he has this great
reaction where he's just like and you
get that great sequence where he punches
apocalypse around for a while because
you know what everyone would have just
been like why didn't Quicksilver just
beat up apocalypse because he's so fast
so they had to address that and they
found a very fun way to address that for
me the most impactful and powerful
this movie and the one that riveted me
from the rest of the runtime on
was Magneto and his family in the forest
that is a great scene it's one of the
best scenes in my opinion of any x-men
film his performance the the weights of
it all the impact it just it worked
extremely well following that the
sequence where he visits the mill he
worked at and he has that amazing speech
where he tells all of those workers that
ratted him out to the police straight to
their face just think about whoever you
care for most they're about to lose
someone they love and I was like oh shit
magneto in this film was fantastic as
usual Michael Fassbender was great as
the character I didn't think he was
sidelined at all I thought a lot of this
film really relied on him and that
moment towards the end where he finally
goes against apocalypse and it's like I
didn't betray you
I betrayed him I got chills man I got
chills down my back it was great let's
talk about Apocalypse himself and this
is a iffy thing for a lot of people in
fact on the first viewing I was a little
bit off and on with him as well he
started out and I was like oh this could
be really cheesy this could not work out
but as he went along with his way of
speaking the way they did his audio I
really liked it I do think he should
have been bigger though and that could
easily be achieved with modern-day CGI
but in the long run I am fine with it
because I what really can you really
achieve script wise dialogue wise by
making one guy a little bigger I mean it
doesn't really do anything really for
your story
if your characters slightly bigger I
guess you'd be more physically imposing
but in the long run what does that
really do for the film you still have to
craft a compelling villain through
dialogue and I think they did one
complaint I'm hearing a lot is that
Jennifer Lawrence isn't mystique enough
because in first class she decides to be
mutant and proud so why would she
continuously hide in her Jennifer
Lawrence face rather than being her Blu
self they do address it in this movie
she doesn't want to be that person that
was on the news that everyone suddenly
looked towards that everyone respected
all the mutants around the world she
didn't want to be viewed as that person
is it because Jennifer Lawrence was
tired of wearing the blue makeup all the
time I don't know I'm
not there I don't work on the x-men
movies but I think the way they
addressed it in the film worked because
in the long run if you were in that
situation and you had the ability to
hide okay
why not and I loved the final battle
that took place and Professor X's mind
again I got goose bumps when it's like
you're in my house now and just starts
punching a bog level shit this is
awesome this is one of the few x-men's
that really requires you to have a deep
knowledge of the x-men universe and yes
it's easily muddled especially when one
of them is a time travel movie and
that's hard to do especially when other
filmmakers have made x-men movies
because you're stepping into this
University like okay I have to get
everything right and then there's all
these other movies and then you have to
also make a compelling movie on your own
there's so many other x-men movies now
that I think they did the best job they
could and I had a ton of fun with this
movie what are your guys thoughts on
x-men apocalypse now that it's out I'd
love to hear them below guys I'm going
to be doing a office tour
pretty soon of my new filming set we got
a new house and I've been building up a
new set over the past few months and
it's going to be in use probably within
the next few weeks and I'm really
excited to do that that office tour is
going to go up very soon also I want to
tell you guys about this amazing hot toy
I talked to you about it in my review of
Alice Through the Looking Glass I got
this from the big bad toy store it's
Wolverine from the Wolverine I love this
thing I got it at the big bad toy store
they have amazing prices they're one of
my favorite if not my favorite online
toy store and I want to tell you guys
some more often about things that I get
in the background because I get so many
questions about that definitely check
out that store I left a special link for
you in the description below if you want
to click that and check out the items
they have it's a great place for adult
collectors as well as kid collectors
definitely check it out that thing is
beautiful I often look at it and touch
it and maybe put it on my pillow
maybe I definitely do guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
you